when they first even invited you to
participate in the shoot you didn't even
know you're going to be the cover but
when they first asked you to be on the
shoot did you think great idea i can't
wait to do this not at all i said why
and then it was my cia agents they say
they can't believe it but they so
excited that that they want me and then
they said they'll fly me to belize and
now my daughter tosca was with me and
she shot a movie in belize she says
you've got to go if only for belize so
then i said okay
so may what is your beauty routine and
please don't tell me you drink a lot of
water
what is it i'm a dietitian so i eat very
well and i drink when i'm thirsty
and i certainly don't carry water around
with me all the time did you feel
self-conscious about your body you know
this is the uh this is the swimsuit
issue the pictures are great let me just
show you and there's a two-piece and you
wear two wait i'm going to
i had marked it are you self-conscious
about your body well um i've never been
considered a swimsuit model nobody
booked me for swimsuits i've been
modeling since i was 15. so that's
that's a long time yeah look at the
pictures may yes yes and so then um
i i thought well
well i went there but then once i did
the first swimsuit and
they all said oh great great great and
i'm saying okay so
i said to them please photoshop me like
crazy
i didn't do that
but you don't need photoshop
right now well then you have good
lighting here too how did your kids
respond when they saw you on the cover
they said congrats they thought it was
amazing yeah what was you gonna do yeah
you mentioned
yeah tosca describes you as unstoppable
yeah just when you think she's getting
older and she says no not yet
yeah she says you're unstoppable do you
feel unstoppable i'm unstoppable i mean
i'm just getting started and you said at
74 this is the happiest you've ever been
what is the key to happiness um that you
don't mix with nasty people anymore you
don't tolerate that i like that uh you
can say no to things
you know before that you're just very
polite and you do things you don't want
to do
and um
i i just
live alone with my dog the dog makes me
very happy
and
and then i flower around so much and uh
i'm in demand i mean
you're in demand so speaking speaking of
nasty people and things in demand
there's a social media platform that
exists it's called twitter oh yeah i
heard people think there's some
nastiness yeah somebody recently put a
bid to buy twitter right man and there's
a guy named elon musk your son uh who's
trying to buy the thing i i'm curious do
you ever give him business advice is it
these conversations come up yes i did
tell him don't do a car company electric
car company and a rocket company
yeah and a solar company i said just
choose one you've been working too hard
at paypal so now you need to just choose
one and so obviously he doesn't listen
to me now now may i i work in tv i
played in the nfl for 11 years
oftentimes my mom will call me and
she'll say son
what did you just say you shouldn't have
said it and then why did you do it why
did you do that have you ever called
elon and said i saw what you wrote on
twitter or i heard what you said dial it
back no no no you allow him to choose
his words
say what he wants you you have to be
responsible for whatever you say and and
yesterday i was tweeting out all the
bots that have seven followers but a
thousand likes and they are all
malicious comments yeah so but these
people don't have any followers how do
they get a thousand people liking their
malicious statements and then
retweeting it 400 times yeah so yeah you
and retweeting it with saying
more malicious things yeah no there's
there's something organized that's going
on that way you can't just make that up
you're active on twitter uh yes are
there other changes you hope your son
brings to the platform
oh actually haven't given much thought
other than yesterday i was angry
but you were hashtag angry mom
nothing wrong with that angry no nothing
wrong with that at all you were fiercely
protective of him he recently tweeted if
something happens to me and i die of
unforeseen circumstances which i thought
was very troubling when i read it what
do you think are you worried about his
safety what do you think when he tweets
things like that well when i see all the
malicious
um
comments on twitter then i really do
worry about him yes
i mean
a mother always worries about her
children i've got three but he's the one
i'm worried about yeah elon is a very
polarizing figure and people are
interested in him yeah um but i'm
curious about what he was like when he
was younger me too when you saw him in
my book
i left some copies here for you
thank you for that but what was it like
when you looked in his eyes when he was
a child or a teenager did you see
this man who was eventually going to
have such an impact on the world well at
three i said you've got to go to i took
him to nursery school because i already
had two other little babies and i said
and and they said but it's a bit young
to send him to nursery school and i said
but he's a genius and they rolled their
eyes every parent says that you thought
he was a genius of three why why did you
think that he would converse with me and
make sense and and he was so observant
of things wow and very curious
and um
yeah so i was right yes
you have a nickname for him do you have
a pet name for him i'm curious um we
used to call him genius boy
when it comes to geniuses i hear that
they have tremendous strengths um but
they're also so it's like after it
spills it spills the milk on the counter
okay genius okay
um
are there any weaknesses and i don't
want to say weaknesses it's a weird word
to use but when you look at geniuses
oftentimes there's things that they have
hang-ups about is there anything that
you know the when you have a genius they
could be in the basement doing genius
things and never apply it
and fortunately elon also has a business
brain and he realizes that what he wants
to do he needs to apply it and
he has to go through a lot of hardships
to fight the fossil fuel industry and
i actually think he's brilliant and just
always thinking outside the box
and he's a doer he doesn't just have an
idea he wants to execute his ideas but i
want to end with you because i'm so i'm
i'm so in awe of this cover it is i'm so
proud of you i want to be you when i
grow up may musk but this cover is a
symbol of beauty for so many people when
we look at it when do you feel you're
most beautiful
well first of all with this cover i want
women to be able to walk on the beach in
a swimsuit and not be embarrassed about
their bodies
because we we are like that and men will
walk out and they would be obese and
then then they have a kind of work
and then they they arrogant and
confident i'm saying
you know and we don't insult them but
man when we walk down the beach we get
we get comments yeah so we just got to
get um those are weak men by the way
thank you i agree with you i agree with
you 100 yes all right bravo and thank
you thank you